do you believe characters drive
plot yes oh okay i was gonna say or is
it the other way around it sounds like
you're very yes it's it's imperative
they obviously go hand in hand but
if you don't have again that intriguing
character
that we're going to root for and we care
about
then it just is going to fall apart for
you
in your story that's just again my
opinion
um it's interesting because i feel like
there have been
you know some movies and shows made
recently and they they go for this
you know anti-hero and you know again if
done you know
we were talking earlier one of my
favorite shows of all time is
californication
and you know you have this anti-hero
who is you
he's a rogue he's this this charming
rogue
and he is so self-destructive
and he just you know gets in his own way
all the time but he's got heart
and he loves his daughter and he's in
love with his
estranged girlfriend and he
you know as as infuriating as he can be
he still keeps us watching because again
we do want to see what he's going to do
next because he's capable of anything
but that we really do care about him not
just because he's hilarious he's funny
and he's a
he's you know wizard with words he's a
writer in the series
but he is but he's just
you know there's something just that we
we care about him at the end of it all
through those seven seasons and
i feel like you know at times i lately
i've watched some shows
and again it's just my opinions that i
feel like i'm not
you know really on the side of any i'm
not really rooting for anyone and i
think
i know the audience wants people to root
for
so if you don't have that character
developed in a way that we're gonna
you're gonna really have and again not
all stories need
the character needs an arc things do
happen to them but i i feel like
the end of it all we do want to see
something happen to our character
him or her that changes them and that we
really
even if they start at the place where
they're you know a loathsome character
by the end we want to see them redeemed
in some way i think that's just
our natural inclination you know as
humans you know i think we do
we do love a good um
uh you know in a way not you know a
redemption story but
seeing a character or or character is
redeemed
um so yeah i feel like to just the most
important thing you can do
is you know again as as i referenced
earlier having those beats
those beats are for your character what
are the changes to your character yes it
obviously goes hand in hand with the
plot
but how is your character being changed
by this story and how are they
subsequently changing the story um
i think every beat really does hinge on
their
decisions and what their what they're
choosing to do in
in the story without a doubt you said
earlier you really like to have the
pacing
good and to really push the story along
has it ever happened where
someone's looked at your script and said
you know what the character is changing
too soon slow it down
or vice versa sure i i i
um yeah there's definitely that
over the years where i've probably
gotten that note um
[Music]
i it it has happened i don't recall
on which particular script but it has
happened for sure
um and i think it's easy you know
especially in early drafts when you
write an earlier draft and you're
wanting to get it down you know you've
plotted it you have it
set you have the story set you know you
have your turns
um they're hard turns your your you know
people looked at it they're like this is
a really good outline
you know time to go right um
where yeah where it sometimes doesn't
always translate to um
you know you may start doing the
character may start
developing a little too soon i think if
that's the case then you kind of have to
go back to the outline
and just you know that's why having good
structure is important is going back to
the outline and
using it as a reference saying okay
here's where i need that character to
change and etc
so yeah i i i do i do think it's um
um you know it's um
it's one of those things where yeah you
there are a lot of times that
again earlier drafts where you may be
having a character evolve too soon
rather than giving them
her a you know letting it gestate a
little bit more
zack what if that outline fails you what
if you outline
and then you get to the screenplay and
then
it doesn't work great question
um i i think that
it's sort of you know one of those
things where i
i'll say this it's important i i've
been part of i've been part of many
writers groups over the years and i've
recently
been part of another one um for the last
couple of years
i feel like if you have a good um
you know if you have a writer's group in
place that that can really help you see
certain things
um fellow writers i should say
that sometimes can can really help
and can steer your and and i always feel
like those sessions that i have with
them
provide invaluable feedback um i don't
always use all of it
uh but sometimes i walked away with like
that's a great idea
um more to the point about whether an
outline fails
and the script doesn't work um
i i fortunately have especially in my
later scripts have always
really worked the outline so that i
i feel like it's pretty it it's it's
pretty solid
um but i would say that
again going back to what i referenced
earlier if you feel that you've done the
outline you've done the due diligence on
that and you've done the script and it's
not working
i would say go back and re-examine i
think you have to ask yourself why is
this failing
like where where is it landing flat why
is it not because there's a lot of
different
you know
[Music]
areas where you could be coming up short
i'm sure you know
um but i think it's
it's fair to ask yourself okay where is
this coming up short
going you may not have to throw it all
out but going back to the outline and
seeing okay
maybe re-examining the outline and then
taking it and and reworking the script
again
based on that new outline um or again it
just may be one of those things where
the story just isn't materializing and
you again just maybe need to put that
away for now
and move on to into another idea another
story
um but you know again
my my advice would be really again to
really
with the outline to really work it well
to get your to have your
your your your key beats down and to get
feedback
i think it's really important to also
get feedback from other writers
um and you know not and people give you
a fair
will give you a fair you know fair
hearing i don't
i don't think you should why i don't
think you should be going to your mom
to get hurt because your mom and or your
dad or
you know aunt sue and uncle johnny are
gonna love it no matter what they're
they're there to champion you and root
you on
i also don't think it's great to go to
somebody who you may know
is you know you want
you who's especially or unduly harsh i
feel like you want people
who can be fair and with their
constructive criticism and say okay
this is good this is good but this
doesn't work i i think
just you know i knew a few people in
college
and again we were just starting out who
would just rip
rip you know his or her fellow students
apart it was just
i was like what's wrong with you you
know we're so i think you have to
you have to encourage that you know you
always have to give encouragement but
i think you could do it in a fair and
critical way but i don't think you have
to rip the person apart
personally so i think it's finding that
good balance and finding
a good group of people whom you trust
who will give you fair
and critical feedback and you know from
there i think
you know um then it's about determining
the direction you want to go in do you
go back and rework it
or do you just say you know what i'm
going to shell this for now and move on
and i've known plenty of people who have
done both
and um uh again
it's yes look i i've started outlines
and i've got an amount of people and i
haven't written a word
and this this happened in the last few
years i wrote a number of outlines
and i gave them to people who i was um
i i value their opinion and they said
you know what
this character just isn't likable or
this plot just isn't this this just
isn't working mostly had to do with the
character
you know these characters are just
highly unlikable and i don't see you
really
you know making it um uh you know making
this as a film that
that anyone's you know really going to
get um
you know again have any empathy for
anyone that this
this was one this is i'm just this was
one script in mind that that comes to
mind
um and another outline where it was just
like
yeah but it's just certain elements just
seem to be too much of a stretch so
i know for me it's like if that outline
isn't working and i'm getting feedback
and it's not coming in and there are
people who
i trust who are really giving me
i feel their a fair assessment
and i was like okay well i think i it
maybe it's just better i move on and
maybe later on i'll come back to this or
but this just doesn't seem to be hitting
the the notes that i wanted to
you